i miss you both so much
that's kind of a waste of time too why
because
we never left you grey's anatomy brought
back two more beloved characters on
thursday night
eric danes mark sloane and kyler lee's
lexi gray
i actually like i think i loved rules
you totally did
[Music]
of course the pair appear on the beach
with meredith and she asks whether
they're still together
so you two are together
on your beach looks like we are
you'll remember mark died in the season
nine premiere of the show
following the plane crash that killed
lexi during the season eight finale
just a couple years back e.t asked eric
if he would ever return to gray's
would you ever come back in some sort of
like flashback
ghost situation they named the hospital
after me
so i don't i don't know if i need to
come back it's always just i'm always
just kind of there
you know i have never really left
but that was a great experience i you
know i think uh
i think we've jumped the shark enough
with that show i don't know if they'll
bring me back as a ghost
and recently camilla ludington hinted at
kyler's return
are we gonna see any females
return you're just getting it lexi
because she's been trending since last
week on twitter right
i can reveal that i just read a script
like literally in the past two weeks
that completely floored me
i had no idea and it's wild
more shocking than patrick's return
or as shocking to me it was more
shocking
this season of greys has been filled
with surprises both tr knight and
patrick dempsey have
also popped up
[Music]
fans are worried all these fan favorite
return cameos could mean this is the
final season
both show runner krista vernoff and
meredith herself ellen pompeo have
suggested it could be
we honestly have not decided we're
really trying to figure it out right now
you're in the middle of deciding whether
it ends or it doesn't say it's what
story do we tell
to end a show this iconic
how you know how do we do it but other
cast members have told et
that's likely not the case where do you
stand
i don't i don't think so i think it i
look i i i don't know but
i think the show is too important to
go out without a damn parade i think
that collectively
they create they've decided you know
what we're not going to put an end on it
we're just going to wait and feed
especially in light of what's happening
right now it's like do we want the last
season to be about coven
or we wanted you know us to be able to
put some nice ribbons
around it with rainbows and balloons and
[Music]
things